this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app do you
want to get paid five dollars and also
give five dollars to charity of course
because United Neiman do you want to buy
and sell Bitcoin instantly or get your
paycheck deposited right into the app of
course because a human well the cash app
is the number one finance app in the App
Store and I use it so you should do so
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now this episode is also brought
to you by blue apron blue apron is the
leading meal kit delivery service in the
US and while many people know what we do
we may not know the types of meals that
we eat when we cook but we do with blue
apron because blue apron is amazing and
they tell you what you get and you look
at it and you make it
I've been eating blue apron now for
weeks months and I it's it's really good
it's it's better than anything you would
order it's better than anything you
would you would you would buy it's just
a great way to you know you make stuff
like seared steaks and thyme pan sauce
with mashed potatoes green beans and
spicy shallots and it takes like 40
minutes or less so and you don't have to
take your trip to the grocery store they
just deliver it blue apron is treating
my listeners with their first three
meals a $30 value with your first order
if visit blue apron home slash Congrats
so check out this week's menu and get
your $30 off with free shipping at blue
apron Dom / congrats blue apron a better
way to cook I'm telling you it really is
good it's got great food everyone I
talked to agrees
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey what's up guys and girls guys kind
of encompasses all I know that maybe
people would think that that's not okay
but it's how we do it here at the
podcast I would say people that's what
Kevin Hart always says hey people sounds
a little bit like you're people if you
call people people it makes it sound
like we're animals even though you're
saying people do you know what I mean so
yeah we're here man I did I was sick for
like two days almost just knocked me the
[ __ ] out
everyone's getting the flu everyone's
getting sick and I woke up I felt bad on
Friday and then I woke up Saturday and I
was like oh it's gonna be one of those
things that's just this bad and I woke
up on Saturday and I didn't all day I
felt like whatever like yeah and then I
went to the comedy store did my set came
home started feeling like yeah but I was
like I just cuz it's nighttime tomorrow
I'm gonna wake up and I'm gonna go
gangbusters I woke up on Sunday with a
hundred and two fever
ah my brain was frying so I was doing
that for a day for a day and then woke
up the next day with a hundred fever
knocked it down
two [ __ ] degrees with just some bed
rest and chillin and watching the first
20 minutes on stuff of stuff on Hulu and
Netflix and Amazon Prime and then giving
up on it and trying something new and
then I woke up the next day and bought
up up by yeah I'm loving it cuz I'm all
better and that's the next day was was
yesterday and then today is the whole
new day so so I'm I'm chilling and I'm
good and this thing people were getting
the flu for like seven days one fire had
it for like a week and a half
get out of here dude
[ __ ] my [ __ ] was like hey what's up
nice to meet you my [ __ ] was like how
you treat the Census Bureau when they
come to your door or like Jehovah's
Witness hi we'd like to learn a Mormon
missionaries I would like to talk to you
about a really good gunk that's what I
said to the flu dude hey ant hey no no
antibodies with a good thing hey
bacteria what's going on dude do me a
favor turn around
gheh gunk that's what I did to my
bacteria my antibodies were [ __ ]
straight up killing them I don't even
know if that's right I'm medical though
dude I'm [ __ ] really medical so you
know what I did because I kept [ __ ]
killing it when I get when I was sick I
kept I kept being like this I'm sick
baby but and then when I to make myself
feel better I was going [ __ ] yeah dude
how could you be sick that's that's the
thing dude I had 102 fever and I go like
this to myself I'd be like oh man I
don't feel so do almost up but [ __ ] it
do it and I'd have a headache but I got
up anyway do it and I did this [ __ ] and
you think I don't dance dude alone I
[ __ ] dance alone in my bedroom
cuz I'm that [ __ ] dude I would
be like oh I mean I had my body wasn't a
key that's the thing dude the two worst
things about being sick and having the
fever having a fever not that fever
because I'm not a foreign exchange
student did you have the fever is are
the chills dude that [ __ ] will kill you
bro and and the bangin s and and the
bangin ass body aches dude those are the
worst but I had a [ __ ] mild to
hardcore headache it wasn't like the
Morse headache I ever had and then a
little bit of chill I had some chills
but then
not bad mucus so I was like my body was
like the gunk in the [ __ ] bacteria
and I knew it was dude because I'd be
like oh man remember what I was talking
about if something hit me in the head I
would pretend I'd be knocked out for a
little bit for like seven minutes and
that just to be dramatic for myself
that's what the sickness was I was like
oh man I don't really feel good I don't
really know what's going on dude man I
wonder how long this is gonna last but
anyway [ __ ] it [ __ ] - nobody my dogs
are looking at me
what's up butters you [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
you ain't [ __ ] oh man I don't feel good
Sam you guys think I'll make it another
day
I'm confident [ __ ] but anyway you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm your [ __ ] dad I'm
your [ __ ] dad and you can't live
without me dogs literally you need
someone to pour your [ __ ] food out
for you otherwise you die and me even
though I'm sick dude this is only gonna
last it's all just like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] bitch-ass dogs you die without me
and that [ __ ] made me better dude you
really did it made me better do it it's
all in the mind man how about when
people tell you how much it's in the
mind it's not really that much in the
mind though because like you fracture
your [ __ ] what's the [ __ ] thing I
was gonna say fibia but it's tibia tibia
fibia how many bones run with a BIA
whatever if you fracture a [ __ ] a BIA
bone that's not in your mind I don't
know but the truth is what did we learn
dude
health is wealth and when people say
that one murder 'im but it's the truth
man health is wealth man because that's
the thing I was talking about this with
with one of my buddies and I was like
you know what when you're sick on your
back you're just like did I don't give a
[ __ ] about anything I don't care about
money I don't care about [ __ ] getting
laid like dude when you're sick guys
don't know what I'm talking about
first of all how horny are guys all the
time just
yeah true of course that's just how it
is guys all right but when you're sick
dude you are not like whatever the the
most hottest girl could come up to you
and be like I was just thinking did you
want to do the horizontal mambo and
you'd be like no I'm sick darling but
you don't give a [ __ ] about anything
when you're sick dude
and that's how you know you'll and then
you're just like a health is wealth but
then but then when you [ __ ] what do
you call it when you when you get when
you get when you get better dude because
they're you're like health as well money
doesn't matter chicks don't matter
family only the only thing that matters
is family I hope they're okay and you're
getting emotional and [ __ ] but then as
soon as you get better dude
[Music]
and you're like let's make this [ __ ]
money how dumb is the mind you know you
literally that's what I do and then I go
like this and I just roll to the coffee
bean and I'm like let's make this money
but there's no money to be made a coffee
bean but that's how I feel though what
are they saying in that song North
Carolina and South Carolina South
Carolina and North Carolina just saying
all sorts of Carolinas but that's the
thing though dude when you get better
you're like health is wealth but also
let's make this [ __ ] money what does
he say right
yeah saying so many places North
Carolina Virginia South Carolina
Mississippi and sippy more in standard
Alabama shooting in this Jennifer Nana
Virginia ninny Nana medicine in the
California Zimbabwe if I made a man and
a Sweden man I'm in a meeting
dude you know what uh I was listening
you know how you'll be list the best
jay-z lyric I don't we talked about
jay-z a lot forget it dude first of all
he goes what's the [ __ ] one where he
goes house in a song and he is just like
get out you get out you're good ditches
like he's Thanksgiving a site like he's
Thanksgiving dinner say what is that one
get out you could ditches like he's
Thanksgiving and say oh why I heard that
[ __ ] I couldn't believe it and now I
[ __ ] don't have it anymore
look up Thanksgiving dishes for jay-z
don't let me die it's an art Kelly one
where it's it's it's the song this time
I'm gonna refer to arkla it's the song
with jay-z and the guy who pees on
chicks it's big chips okay can't repeat
it cuz got the n-word in it
get out good dishes is something like
his Thanksgiving or something is my
favorite part
get out you good ji kanika dishes I'm
like Thanksgiving or something Oh get
out you good dishes likes Thanksgiving
to say why didn't he say it like that
Oh cause it rhymed with coming that's
why I said bring oh dude so good I [ __ ]
you don't understand dude when I'm in
the car and I hear [ __ ] like this by
myself I go oh today good this is like
Thanksgiving to say you know you good
this is a son likes Thanksgiving so
disrespect just today good dishes like
some [ __ ] Thanksgiving he's rapping
anyway I'm [ __ ] back in black dude I'm
better and I'm going to Cleveland
tomorrow took a flight out to Cleveland
like Allison
- [ __ ] - flat-out clearly lysine - buck
was the only rapper that would rhyme
something that already rhymes or
something more than it rhymes cleveland
rhymes with even in kinda already but
he'd be like Cleveland that's the me I
made it rhyme more already rhymed oh
wait hold on I forgot the best the best
Jake the Jake the best jay-z's lyric I
forgot about this one I forgot about
that one one fire brought it up cuz we
always talked about this I was on the
Peter Pan plus he's use Putin Peter
Peter Peter boom
Oh what no obviously Peter Pan Bus is
something that I don't know about but I
Sona Peter Pan plus use people Peter Pan
up in the room huh
that quizzical yeah dude I [ __ ] I
love hip-hop man it's so funny anyway
dude I'm better I'm better a [ __ ]
gnome a con dude dude how hilarious
would it be if you saw a car you went to
an Akon [ __ ] concert and you were
just like oh [ __ ] yeah and you and an
acre and and he had all his openers and
[ __ ] so many [ __ ] old flashing lights
and fire just people open for him and
then it was like give it up for [ __ ]
Akon and he comes out and he's [ __ ]
two feet and he's just like and you're
like oh that makes sense and you're just
like [ __ ] and that's why his voice is
like that
oh and he had a [ __ ] big-ass
microphone he was just hugging like the
microphone was like like sometimes he
would just like put the microphone he
would just like stand the microphone up
and hold it like with his hands like
this and he would just be like this and
he would just be like oh and [ __ ]
even like little Uzi vert will come out
and he was like seven feet tall over him
a little Uzi vert there'd little Uzi
vert you know [ __ ] III you know I wanna
every time I see a picture of lil Uzi
vert I want to be like this [ __ ] guy
but then whenever I see lil Uzi vert in
like a video that like goes viral where
he's like talking to fans he looks like
the nicest guy and I just want to be
like that guy's [ __ ] cool
so just be like yeah what up man we just
hey what's up cool you having a good day
cool are you having a good time oh cool
how's your life oh nice you guys gonna
stay in school okay check you later
you're like oh the guys just [ __ ]
nice as [ __ ] dude [ __ ] how funny
would that be I literally can't even
think of a [ __ ] Akon song right now
but to have him come out and just be
like
what's this one oh yeah mad that wasn't
the good one the what the banger coming
up and it's just two feet because I'm so
short I can't see your face close it
fall around up there what's the real
banger song though I like the [ __ ]
you know what I actually have it and
that's the one I'm so paid dude that one
man one fire with the pump 1 or higher
cuz one fire I'll tell you what one fire
has a few jobs here one is to run the
[ __ ] podcast and the other one is to
plug in the [ __ ] headphones now when
I [ __ ] went to go put the headphones
on the thing they're dead
oh that's cuz what can one fire wasn't
here's one fire to do it you know what
really living up to the one fire too
late and label this is the banger though
[Music]
dude they got it they gotta brag before
the song starts
[Music]
not good genes - have you ever seen
convict genes I've never seen him
rotting on that intelligent allow those
counterfeit tools are size 20/20 you
know how I mean Google convict genes
literally convict genes came up like can
like like like like no you spelled with
a k dude I say it like you're the idiot
oh oh did I was looking I was like I was
thinking about like I was like you know
it's you know what [ __ ] time it is
dude it's not for [ __ ] daddy to step
is [ __ ] goddamn game up man bro you
see the pink jacket I got on Instagram
first of all I saw Russell Westbrook I
can't say Russell Westbrook's name
without saying Russell Westbrook it's
like all of a sudden I become [ __ ]
deaf
Russell Westbrook it's weird it's like
Russell what it makes me want to go the
are Russell West Russell I can't say
Russell Westbrook anyway whatever when I
say it fast it goes like that
but Russell recipe book why can't it
[ __ ] say it anyway he got that pink
jacket on and I was like bro what is
that jacket I'm gonna pay [ __ ] seven
grand for it I don't give a [ __ ] what it
is where is it I found out it was from
Urban Outfitters and it's $100 bro I
went and and I got it and I [ __ ] wore
it out that [ __ ] is hot and I was like
but it's time for me to step my [ __ ]
game up bro look cuz here's the here's
the thing I you know I'm a shoe guy I
love shoes but I was like I gotta get
some real [ __ ] dude I gotta go to Gucci
and get like a Gucci jacket or something
and then I looked up Gucci jackets you
know how much a [ __ ] jean jacket from
Gucci's it's like eight grand ah
and you know the Gucci jackets are cool
but then the front is cool but then you
look at the back and it's got like it
might as well have [ __ ] like
embroidered [ __ ] on it it's it'll have
like a planet and then it'll be like
love or die and you're like I don't want
what's up with these [ __ ] shirts that
are like make such grand statements like
literally not a fashion statement like
an actual statement where it'll be like
love is blind what you know why do you
want it it's like why do you want to
make such a statement with a statement
on the back of your [ __ ] jacket live
free or die
yeah oh obviously dude Saab vyas you
know but also I don't need to be
reminded of that every time you [ __ ]
turn around people are done with their
outfits dude I know that the fashion
industry is I know I talk about this a
lot but the fashion industry has just
taken us for a [ __ ] ride
why is high fashion the [ __ ] [ __ ]
where would they do the runways and they
do the [ __ ] and everything you see that
is like with if it's Versace or like
Gucci or [ __ ] what's that one I like
da Vinci like every time you see a show
of theirs it's like some guy with a
microwave on his head and and a [ __ ]
and and a like a leather jacket that
like [ __ ] goes below his feet all the
way below his feet and it drags and
you're like wow high fashion he's got a
microwave on his head and then but
that's not what they sell that's what
they [ __ ] sell they'll just and then
you go to the store and you're like hey
where's the [ __ ] microwave head
outfit and they're like oh no that was
just for the show but you can buy a
sweater for seven grand if you want no I
want the [ __ ] microwave head thing
you take me for a [ __ ] ride he comes
out with a little microwave on his head
and a jack and a little jacket he just
has a little piece of leather he's gonna
like this
right it's like he's trying to make a
wish right Robin I'm not telling your
mother can't convict baby convict baby
teens all right
square cash if you haven't heard look
we're switching to the cash app all
right I've done it I've switched to the
cash app so you do it too if you want to
come to the log cabin it's the simplest
way to pay people back and these
sponsors man they they they're they help
us do this podcast so you switch because
I switch and you want to get to the log
cabin you can pay anyone back with this
electronically friends family very
thoughtful wedding yes you can pay a con
back with it
setting and receiving money is totally
free and fast and most payments can be
deposited directly in your bank account
in just a few seconds okay
did you don't think the cash lets you do
way more than that now you can even buy
and sell Bitcoin instantly get your
paycheck deposited right to the app pull
money out of the ATM with the free
custom cash card or use it to spend
anywhere you like you really won't find
more useful finance app out there and of
course when you download the fact the
cash app $5 goes to you and $5 goes to
the times up Legal Defense Fund it's
great I use it all the time I use it
weekly I pick up my back all the time
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now I love brute blue apron brew
apron do I love brew apron no I love
blue apron okay it's the number one
fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the country blue aprons
mission is to make incredible home
cooking accessible to everyone
blue apron achieves this by supporting a
more sustainable food system setting the
highest standards for ingredients and
building a community of home chefs they
offer three plans the two-person meal
plan the family meal plan or the wine
plan which is six bottles of wine from
renowned wine makers delivered monthly
and that's awesome because you know a
guy like me I don't know what I'm
drinking
what people like so I just get the wine
plan and then I I give it to the people
that come over when I want to entertain
but blue apron is awesome every meal
I've had from blue apron I'm telling you
right now every meal I've had has been
really good not just good it's been
really good
it's it they're really good at what they
do I'm not just saying this blue apron
is treating my listeners to their first
three meals a $30 value with your first
order if you visit blue apron com /
Congrats so check out this week's menu
and get your $30 off with free shipping
at blue apron calm / Congrats blue apron
a better way to cook I got a busy day
today
I had to fit it all in because yesterday
I had I was sick and I couldn't do
anything I canceled everything I've got
some auditions now your boy auditions
sometimes no I don't like to because
here's the thing uh-huh
Hollywood is weird how it is all right
it's like guys way above me are
auditioning like he if I hears like I do
get offers to do stuff like but it's
usually comedy right but like if I have
to like if they're like oh yeah they're
interested in you playing a doctor on
[ __ ] you know ABC or or they'll be
like well let's let's read them because
you know we don't know if he can say
succinylcholine and and not have it be
it'll [ __ ] laugh out loud hilarious
right which is whatever but so I
understand that but dude there's the way
Hollywood does it is hundreds of people
will audition for these parts and it's
just so [ __ ] ridiculous
because they should just pick they
should just pick
should just pick they got movies that
are coming out that are like comedies
that are like that like everyone's
auditioning for that you'd be like what
what they why are they auditioning and
it's like you can just you just know if
you have any sort of vision at all and
you're a director just pick the [ __ ]
guy you want to be what's his name um
who's the guy that looked exactly like
me in the [ __ ] new ABC show that
Bobby Lee's on Hudson Oliver Hudson you
know what he does okay if you want him
to be in a movie
have him be in the [ __ ] movie don't
call the guy in the right now that guy
probably does get offers so I'm this is
wrong but like there's so many guys like
at that level that it's like you know
what the [ __ ] guy does uh like Bobby
but you know what Bobby leaves a great
[ __ ] example actually how you gonna
make Bobby Lee [ __ ] audition for a
movie Bobby Lee's been around for 75
years and he and you know what he does
especially in a comedy he should never
have to test for any show ever if you
have any sort of vision at all you can
see oh I want Bobby Lee for that part
but Bobby Lee has to [ __ ] an audition
every now and then and that's so
annoying for Bobby Lee and you you're
wasting time you know he can [ __ ] do
it Bobby Lee's [ __ ] hilarious
um but it's it's it's just like all
these [ __ ] hoops that you have to
jump through as an actor I'm auditioning
for for two things later and you know
and and here's the other thing too dude
getting the [ __ ] sides sides are
things that you are the are the part the
few pages that you read for the audition
right so it'll be like eight pages of
sides some of these [ __ ] TV shows
will be like hey here are the sides and
it'll be like 12 pages hey dude
[ __ ] my ass are you that's half the
script sometimes twelve pages you
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude make it five at the
most okay if you can't see what I do in
five pages you got a bad script okay
like [ __ ] and then and then and then and
then dude even better even better dude
some of these [ __ ] movies will be
like yeah my agents assistant will hit
me up and be like oh you yeah they
they're the casting is sending you a
link
they're emailing you a link directly to
download the sides because they won't
send them through me because they don't
want they want it to be you know what do
you call it harder to get like exclusive
or like I don't know I can't look at the
right word but like it's a private and
they don't want it to get out there you
know and and and you're like okay and
you wait for the email from casting and
you'll get some [ __ ] email from like
dink donk zip and you're like and you
look at it and it's like oh down oh you
got to go to ember shot to download to
download the thing so you'll click on
the link and it's like ember shot calm
and then go to ember shot and then it'll
be like ah do you want to
open the ember shot app and you're like
what and then you click it and it'll be
like do you want to download the app and
you're like no give me the [ __ ] sides
and then and then you but and then you
get hit back to the agent assistant and
you're like hey it says I got to log in
and they're like oh really
hold on and then they'll send it back to
the person and they'll be the person in
the production office and they'll be
like oh ok you got to create a login and
I'm like nah
and then so the asian assistant will do
it it'll be like I created a login for
you it's [ __ ] you know and it's
always something like you know Chris 70
and so I'll put in Chris 70 and it it
never works the first time so then I
gotta go back yeah it's not working and
then they stated like oh it should work
and then I tried a second time and it
works and it's not my fault and I know
it's like well I worked the first time
it nah some of these [ __ ] logins dude
they're made so they don't work the
first time I swear to [ __ ] god dude
and then you'll get it and then it'll be
like oh it'll be too small it'll be too
[ __ ] small and then you so you got to
get the app so now I'm downloading the
[ __ ] ember shot app and I get it and
and and I and I look and and now it's
like printed yeah and and it's for like
and and you'd think this is for [ __ ]
Star Wars and it's for some [ __ ] like in
the army now reboot and you're like who
the [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] this much about in
the army now reboot who gives a flying
[ __ ] these production companies think
that these move nobody gives a [ __ ]
about your goddamn movie if it was in a
movie yet if it's not number 4 oh yeah
we don't
decides to get out because we're worried
about the the the blogosphere getting
the [ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ] and I
got to do [ __ ] all this [ __ ] and then
I got to read five pages and then I got
a it's some [ __ ] it's so dumb dude the
whole thing so dumb you know that
[ __ ] Bobby Lee can play taxi driver
in a [ __ ] movie with Paul Rudd you
nut I mean you know well it's so
ridiculous the way they do it anyway
mm-hmm so I got to do two of those later
and therefore [ __ ] that I think are good
cuz otherwise I just I'm like no no no
no no I I fight my agents - I don't
fight them but I'm like I'm not going
out on that what do they want me no they
want me to read for it and I'm not going
out no you know why dude you know why
you know why - because people don't know
this but if you have any sort of a
fanbase as a comedian you're making way
more money on the road people think like
oh people in TV are all rich if your
show goes for [ __ ] six seasons yeah
you're [ __ ] sitting pretty but if
you're like on like different shows that
come out sometimes and you know you did
like sick you show got six episodes and
you did a season of a show here you're
you're [ __ ] broke and you're trying
to make you got to take the next job
you're like oh where's the [ __ ] job
coming dude and then so they're like oh
yeah let's have Chris D'Elia or [ __ ]
reefer dude no you know what I'll go to
Cleveland or [ __ ] whatever and make
more money doing a literally exactly
what I want to do rather than
having to play some [ __ ] guy in some
paint-by-numbers Network show I mean
some of these network shows are good you
know but some of these network shows are
just it's like yeah well we're just
making the law you're one again we're
gonna make a lawyer show again this year
but this one's different though because
she was a she's a woman and she was
molested and now she fights cases for
people that were molested oh cool oh and
she's a black belt oh all right well
okay yes so she can kick ass and kick
ass if you know what I mean yeah yeah
sounds good and it gets picked up
because it's a strong female lead and
then cancelled in five [ __ ] episodes
ridiculous [ __ ] ridiculous
coming to the second reads quip if
you're a person with a mouth which you
are it's likely you don't brush your
teeth for a full two minutes change your
brush on time or brush twice a day quit
gets that so they've designed the
perfect electric toothbrush quip is the
new electronic a sorry electric
toothbrush that packs just the right
amount of vibrations into a slimmer
design at a fraction of the cost of
bulkier traditional electric brushes and
guiding pulses alert you when to switch
sides that's pretty cool making brushing
the right amount of effortless quip
comes with a mount that suctions right
to your mirror and unstick on sticks to
use as a cover for hygienic travel
anywhere whether it's going in your gym
bag or carry on so it's really easy to
use and it's very cool it looks like
it's made by like Apple you know it's
like gold and sleek I bring it on the
road that's the only toothbrush I use
most toothbrushes don't get named one of
Time Magazine's best inventions of the
year but qyp did and you should find out
yourself why clip starts at just $25 and
right now when
go to get quick calm / congrats to get
your first refill pack free with a quick
electric toothbrush that's your first
refill pack free at get quip calm /
Congrats spelled GE t qu IP comm /
Congrats
you never turn down free money right
well if you shop online without the best
coupons you're already paying too much
fortunately there's a free browser
extension called honey that
automatically finds the best coupons on
the web so you always get the best
prices on everything online now it's
weird it's almost like this thing that's
too good to be true one fire has been
turning me on to this it's - it's two
clicks okay you add honey to any browser
for free then shop like you normally do
honey scans and tests millions of
coupons in the background at checkout
honey will automatically apply the best
coupon to get you the biggest discount
over 7 million people use honey every
day and together they've saved saved
millions of dollars you're not gonna
overpay on anything ever again
I when I check out it's the kind of
thing where it's like you go to like
GoDaddy calm to buy something and then
it'll be $15 and then you honey makes it
and so you're paying two dollars i I
went to something it was like a $120
honey figured it out that's like 108
dollars you just saved money for doing
nothing so there's no reason not to add
honey to your browser today do it now
it's free and it takes just seconds to
install and it will save you tons of
money and add honey to your browser for
free right now and joy at join honey
calm / Congrats that's join honey calm /
Congrats I was in a I was doing a I was
getting my mail at my pl box and this
guy first of all I don't even know if
it's legal or not but when you're parked
when you know when two cars are parked
like on the street like
in a lot you know just on the curb and
then a motorcycle can park in between
the kena motorcycle park in between them
I don't know if that's legal or not but
they always do it anyway
I get in my car to leave on parked and
as I'm doing that this guy on a
motorcycle is parking in between the
front of my car and the back of the car
in front of me making it tougher for me
to get out I don't even think about it
but I do afterwards which is now so I'm
like alright cool so I have to I have to
get out so I reversed first and he's on
his motorcycle parking and then I pull
up a little bit and then I pull back and
I have to do like a five-point turn
because of him right which is fine I
don't give a [ __ ] but as I'm doing it
he's looking at me like hey man what the
[ __ ] are you doing and I I don't really
understand what he's upset about so i i
i because i wanna i if he's upset with
me here's the thing I know I've done
nothing wrong right here so I want I'm
looking at him as a potential slam
victim so he's looking at me like hey
what the [ __ ] you doing and I'm like oh
I've got a Rolodex of slams for all
sorts of situations this guy doesn't
know that I've got [ __ ] you know
Denny's Grand Slam breakfast in my back
pocket alright so and I've got it for
him and it's hot and steaming and so I
pull up and I rolled down the window and
I say hey man what's up y'all good is
that everything okay and he says yeah
man uh you almost hit me I said oh I
didn't and he said yeah didn't didn't
you see me I said and here comes the
slam this was great I don't even mean to
do it
I said of course I saw you that's why I
didn't hit you he says yeah well you
were pretty close and I said I you're
all
good right just get hurt and he says nah
but you were pretty close I said ah but
you're all good he says yeah well don't
do that again I said Oh that'll never
happen again and he says and he didn't
like how I was being because of how
utterly right I was and by the way he's
arguing the whole time in a [ __ ]
motorcycle helmet like an idiot and then
he says well man he says oh he says if
you like your car you won't do that
again
like threatening me and I laughed like I
couldn't help myself I went ok man and
he said yo I'm dead-ass I said oh yeah
he said yeah man I'm dead-ass serious
I said are eyebrow and I drove away like
bro
this guy you know [ __ ] is he upset oh
hey bro did you get scared dude did you
get scared cuz I don't my car almost hit
you going one mile an hour while you
made it harder for me to pull out of my
[ __ ] thing dude you made it harder
for me
I'm all good I didn't hit you also if I
hit you congratulations dude you get
money [ __ ] but your dick guy makes it
harder for me and then gets mad at me
dude [ __ ] that bro and then I drove away
just like
[Music]
[ __ ] em man you [ __ ] check the pl box
with his [ __ ] helmet on
hey dude if you if you're a motorcyclist
and you get off of your motorcycle take
the helmet off me idiot lay dude
immediately nobody's having a
conversation with your Tron looking ass
just flipping the [ __ ] up boom hey man
you almost hit me dude
hey hey take it off dude you look like
Daft Punk I'm not having a conversation
with a [ __ ] Tron looking ass [ __ ]
one fire unzipping his [ __ ] backpack
laude [ __ ] more up
that's the zipper that's the sound of
zipper made and he looked like he knew
he was gonna do it and did it anyway cuz
he wanted to get the chapstick dude one
fire needed to get chapstick
we've got like 15 minutes left in this
guy like his lips were gonna in 15
minutes disco and blood was gonna come
out dude I'm [ __ ] straight up on some
new [ __ ] dude how ridiculous is that
song dude when they came up with that
riff they were like Oh life's changed
for everybody dude life's changed for
these people but with that riff it makes
people [ __ ] invincible when you hear
that [ __ ] dude how funny is it to when
you get that song when you're working
out and you're like here we go
[ __ ] and then 20 seconds in
you're like all right dude way home I
gotta take a break and it's still but
it's still goin dude you're just like
alright I'm gonna take a break and it's
still playing like a song generally work
I'm still a [ __ ] and then like Celine
Dion comes on next and you're like I
didn't take it off shuffle or even worse
like the theme song to Mission
Impossible and you cuz you got once for
some jokey reason
[Music]
yeah yeah dude this guy like what would
threaten somebody you know what I was uh
my favorite thing my you don't comment I
get sometimes I get this comment like a
bunch on my Instagram cuz I know I like
I'm a comedian and I know my posts I do
cuz I think they're funny you know and
because I'm I'm a professional comedian
I've got whether you like it or not I've
got a pretty good handle on what's funny
it's my profession I obsess about it not
just through my adult life my whole life
that's why I became a comedian people
comment sometimes wait I wrote down what
they come in I don't understand how
anyone could find this funny like
they'll write like I don't even get why
anybody would find this funny this is so
stupid how could anybody find this funny
I don't understand how anybody could
find this funny and talk about slams
you're slamming yourself you know the
reason let's do a little bit of walking
forward for you
since you're not doing it yourself you
know the reason why you don't understand
why anybody could find this funny is
because you have a bad sense of humor
that's why you slammed yourself so let
me just push you out the door a little
bit cuz you're already almost out there
good gunk dude I don't understand how
anybody can find this funny in the
meantime everybody
ha ha ha ha so funny and me [ __ ]
literally bought real estate or real
estate off of [ __ ] off of comedy you
don't get why anybody could think that
this is funny
when it comes down
brass tacks it's cuz you have a bad
sense of humor
that's why plain mm simp that's the only
reason it could be that's the only
reason it could be
it's literally like saying whoever hits
a home run in baseball and you're like I
don't understand how anyone could say
that's a homerun
those are the rules I mean the comedian
if I put out a joke in professional
space that's funny you I get it
sometimes jokes amiss but like you know
if you're just some person that like
doesn't have anything to do with comedy
let's just go with I'm right people
comment this [ __ ] all day long I don't
get not even just on me I see it our
house is on me this is funny you can
have your opinion but like the reason
why you don't get it because you have a
bad sense here
it's like North Carolina and South
Carolina moving Mississippi and
Mississippi in the jigna any more than a
minute in Sacramento
that's what's like you know that's all
it's like let me see if I have the IG
[ __ ] I hate when people call it Graham
hey did you post it on the Graham I
don't know why I hate that um I'm look I
think I put I think I had a good one but
I don't know if I did it's so funny you
know how you can name the [ __ ]
collections you save on the Instagram I
call a garlic I hurry I won't call Oh
look at these [ __ ] people this is a
workout one okay this is one hey guys
it's time for the most [ __ ] up
Instagram post of the week oh wait hold
on this one's even better I'm not doing
the work I want him doing this one today
okay this [ __ ] guy
oh this guy's [ __ ] famous his [ __ ] I
guess what is he I don't know well he
dresses like a [ __ ] dresses like he's
from Book of Eli why is that that the
most dope like no matter how fashion is
throughout the years always the dopest
fashion is like if you look like you
dress from the movie book of your life
with Denzel Washington this is what the
caption is I wish more people would have
this thing called so first of all it's s
[ __ ] to use the word soul and be like
this thing called soul you didn't
discover what soul is okay you're not
one of the few that's helping push the
soul agenda guy this little thing I like
to call rock and roll you know met this
little guy I like the call Jesus you
know you didn't you know you're not
awakening everything but anybody you'd
be like oh what's this soul thing I wish
more people would have this thing called
soul I wish more people would skip
sleeping for deep conversations at 3:00
a.m.
first of all I disagree with that
completely because if you're somebody
who thinks having deep conversations
that 3m is just oh so something that's
needed
you're a boring person get some sleep
and function at your [ __ ] job better
3 a.m. conversations happen when they
happen when they happen you can't set
them up okay so far your [ __ ] first
two lines on your Instagram story very
goog um Keable extremely good Gunkel
let's see if he can get back in the room
so far you see him pretty good
comfortable he goes on I wish more I
wish people would care more about what's
inside rather than outside okay this is
a picture right now I should tell you
what the picture is off okay
the picture is of a guy looking at
himself in the mirror did here's what I
wish people understood irony better it's
pretty good Gong Keable you're pretty
far outside the room let's see if you
can get back no I don't care how
attractive you think you are hey bud
you're looking in the mirror and also
he's sexy as [ __ ] this guy's a
good-looking guy um if for [ __ ] nuggets
sake dude this this [ __ ] if I saw you
know what I know I said don't you know
threaten people no I'm kidding
no I don't care how attractive you think
you are for [ __ ] I do I can't even this
is like okay no I don't care how
attractive you think you are I'm sorry
dude I'm sorry dude this is no I don't
care how attractive you think you are if
you don't take my soul away first of all
what first of all who wants their soul
taken away Hey
the - - if I if I walked up to somebody
on the street and said I'm going to take
your soul away you'd think I was
Beelzebub
you'd think I came from the very depths
of hell
okay so that so he'd he doesn't mean it
like that
also you should always keep your soul
because it's your soul okay and if it's
and if it's something that you wish more
people would have this thing called soul
then why would you want yours to be
taken away you're so far out the room I
think you can't get back good
gunk that's how that's the door that's
the door slamming baby alright here he
goes on dude
that's not enough be dirty and weird be
shortened out with just homeless be
dirty and weird be sad and happy ah all
the range of emotions don't show up with
the that face you're putting on every
day for the outside world I know it's
easier and less painful but for me it's
perfect
I will tell you
more details about that shoot in the
next post what this guy ladies like by
the way I'm Ahmad I'll tell you more
about this shoot I'm just gonna write no
on it
no I'm gonna write no did you know that
they're commented that wow that was a
good one dude and it's a [ __ ] itself a
guy looking at himself in the mirror
dude unbelievable
that's a [ __ ] gunk alright we're
gonna go we're gonna have a we're gonna
announce an elder God an elder coming up
here it's and her name is Shelby Sharon
now she got two first names
she's pretty [ __ ] up but we're still
making her an elder
she'll be Sharon at she'll be Sharon on
Instagram that's two R's and Sharon she
made this website called true baby and
it's true babies org it's it's took
quite some time to do this and this is
amazing and I I mean I spent some time
perusing on this but you gotta go this
website huge help and a huge she's
spreading this she's really spreading
this it's got he's got a bunch of stuff
from the podcast on there a list of
elder a list of elders artwork stuff
that other elders have made it's it's
really awesome Thank You Shelby will DM
you with the with the with the details
for getting you your your pin in your
certificate I mean this this goes above
and beyond the the call of the call of
action action you're spreading the word
of the call pretty damn well and we
really thank you for that because you
know and you can also donate to the
website which is something that you
should do because it's very cool to to
help help out in any way it can with
this cult that we've we've started
because we've started a cult and that's
just how it is so
Thank You Shelby Sharon should we take
some Twitter questions or should we just
I'm just happy I feel bad or mad yeah
kyle hooper at hoop daddy 10 hmm change
it what do you think of people that pay
hundreds of dollars to go to a concert
but then wear earplugs you know just I
don't the earplugs thing if you go to
concert you should wear earplugs because
you're gonna [ __ ] ruin your hearing
but excuse me so gross but just don't
that's the thing music sounds better
when it's just I know people disagree on
music sounds so much better life no it
doesn't it sounds too loud live get the
CD [ __ ] CD get it on streaming and
just [ __ ] listen to it constantly
bumping around with people there's
always somebody like in camouflage
around you and you're just like why the
[ __ ] that person where it all
camouflage or some [ __ ] you know yeah I
just don't I don't know I don't know I
never like concerts I know you know that
that's pretty funny Cory doc Walker at
doc Walker 26 what do you think about
people who eat their food inside the
McDonald's or Taco Bell or where or
whatever I mean just take it home right
yeah yeah that's true you're supposed to
or at least go in your car and eat it
sad like an adult you know unless you're
like a teenager and like you're just
like out of home and you're like [ __ ]
yeah I get to hang out not at home but
like you know what are you doing would
take it put it in your car like a sad
adult here's another one Charles Taylor
and then I'm gonna blow my nose at uncle
Charlie thoughts on MasterChef junior 8
through 13 year old
8 through 13 year-olds cooking
professional [ __ ] yeah I mean I get I
don't know it's cool when you know what
you want to do as an eight-year-old but
you know you yeah I don't know I guess
it's okay
exploiting these kids I guess one fire
just had to go to the bathroom dude this
guy unzip and one fire just leaves he's
just like I gotta piss
dude there's three minutes left getting
me a what Edition Oh
say ah one higher he's getting me
tissues I'm not gonna blow I'm not gonna
blow my nose though um anyway I think
that's it dude I think that's it just
come back I'm gonna I'm gonna stop in
the end it's been over an hour but yeah
I had a guy i had a fun time on this
podcast man i had a good time so thank
you uh yeah that's good we did a good
one that was fun I had a good time dude
you guys are the [ __ ] man just listening
help me push this podcast going we our
numbers have been real good lately but
they're growing the past two three weeks
they've been growing help do it more
tell people about this you do things
like these websites and all this [ __ ] it
helps man and I'm only gonna be doing
this if it keeps growing like I've said
before so uh yeah it's good it helps me
streamline this cult thing too man it
goes like this
stand-up podcast miscellaneous you know
like movies and TV and then it all rises
up to the tip of the [ __ ] iceberg the
tip of the triangle cult that's how we
do it anyway Square cash have you
switched yet download the free square
cash app enter rewards code rewards code
congrats get $5 give $5 - times up get
it for iOS or Android now blue apron
blue apron check out this week's menu
and get your $30 off at blue apron calm
/ Congrats
follow the leader tour buy tickets on
crystally accom got a bunch of places in
Florida
Charleston just added a Late Show
Pittsburgh Dayton Huntsville Nashville
Denver Late Show added Boise Late Show
added and Cleveland I'll be there it's
all sold out this weekend go get some
merch - at crystally accom support the
podcast subscribe to the YouTube channel
share those videos download the Chris
D'Elia app I just posted a picture of
the wand fire but it is face so you get
this a little bit of a body it's in iOS
or Android the crystal yeah subscribe
rate review the show it really really
helps out thanks a lot appreciate it
video episodes go up Tuesdays or
Wednesdays and watch my specials on
Netflix and share those to those that
helps out I appreciate you guys thank
you very much and a lot
[Music]